the king of Zulus in South Africa is
denying that he's been poisoned that's
after a royal aide said suspected
poisoning was behind his visits to a
hospital in neighboring escort teeny
well familiar Miller joins us from
Johannesburg Familia what more do we
know here there seems to be some
confusion and conflicting reports even
well there's certainly a lot of
confusion around some of these rumors
and the initial story came out from King
Mrs Zulu's Uncle prince botelesi who he
has a good relationship with or
certainly has had in the past that he
had traveled his nephew King Zulu had
traveled to iswatini for medical
attention and that's after one of the
king's aides seems to have been poisoned
that's apparently the thinking because
he had he died quite suddenly quite
unexpectedly so there was perhaps some
concern about what was going on within
that Royal household but following that
King mrsulu traveled to iswatini for
medical attention now that's according
to Prince putalezi his uncle following
that though there's been a statement
that's been issued by King Mrs Zulu's
office saying that he's in good health
that there hasn't been a poisoning and
that he often pays courtesy visits to
iswatini where his uncle King mswati III
uh is is ruling that country so they say
there's been no reason other than the
courtesy visit and while he's there he's
then sought medical attention as a
routine checkup now the it seems as if
the initial part of the story did come
primarily and only from a prince
putalezi his uncle who had spoken to a
couple of hours ago who had said that he
had heard from King Swati in iswatini
from his brother that there was concern
around the poisoning but again that
statement coming from King Mrs Zulu's
office is that he's in good health there
hasn't been a poisoning he's not in
hospital in fact the statement went on
to point out to that they had been
baseless rumors defamatory statements
and they were at pains to express that
the certainly was not the case and that
the king is in good health
thank you
well the uh Zulu Throne has no formal
Powers but still holds political
influence within South Africa's largest
ethnic group
King Zulu's coronation took place in
October he succeeded his late father who
would ruled for five decades his parents
died months apart in 2021 and the later
King gave Mr Zulu's mother the power to
choose a successor well a branch of his
family opposed A succession saying the
throne it should have gone to another of
the previous King's Sons princess and
McCade
well Patika and Thule is a historian and
an expert in South African indigenous
knowledge systems he joins us from
Johannesburg welcome to the program so
what's the political background to this
then there's been a power struggle
hasn't there regarding the king's
accession
yes I've been a very robust a very
ugly contestation to what's the the king
as well as the coronation
there are some of the people within the
royal family who believe that he is not
a legitimate King which is not
absolutely right he is born out of a
princess
it is also the first person of the king
that is that is clear
and the people who are actually
contesting although they are part of the
royal but they are not born out of their
mothers that were exactly anal Queens so
they've been a lot of court cases you
know people uh you know going for this
throw but let me put it this way
in Zulu culture
only one person cooks for the king and
one person feeds the king not even the
king's wives or children feed him in
order to guard against the very in a
matter of you know poisoning
but the poisoning of his You Know Chief
Aid
is a a another matter
are there people inside they will
suspect that what if you buy the only
person that's uh you know feeds the king
and Promises them something but that's
not absolutely the issue it is that the
royalty it was illuminatown and the Zulu
Kingdom has worked up the issues of
poisoning from Seasons time immemorial
who fits the king who does everything to
The King The King safety is entrusted in
a very very very few hands particularly
when it gets onto food one person you
know feeds them not even his favorite
wife is anyway let me let me just jump
and ask you this I mean the monarchs
role may be largely ceremonial in wider
Society but he does will considerable
influence doesn't he
the definitely evils I mean the Civil
Nation is quite one of the biggest and
his history and its struggle against uh
you know colonialism like in 1879 that
defeating the the British war and the
Royal customs and everything that is
very very powerful
and even the late King the father to the
present King also played a very good you
know crucial role when they were
disputes you know amongst the you know
the people within the kingdom and
outside the Kingdom so it is a very very
powerful political force and the Monarch
does have a multi-million dollar
government-funded budget too
yeah they had but a lot of money that's
where they moved all the problem is
because those were actually challenging
him are challenging him you know because
of the resources that might be either
God because when you look at their own
credentials you find that they are
absolutely you know lacking you know
cultural and traditional authenticity
okay we leave it there Patika and Tuli
thank you for joining us here on Al
Jazeera